à jérôme blanchet gravel correspondant
au canada pour spoutnik bonsoir jérôme
blanchet gravel merci d'être avec nous
montréal a donc le canada qui ne vivent
pas manifestement la crise sanitaire
de la même façon pourquoi la ville de
montréal et elle touché de la sorte mais
plusieurs explications parmi les plus
cités je vous dirai d'abord le québec
compte de très très nombreuses personnes
âgées ont le vu le système d'hébergement
des aînés complètement à revoir
une situation qui ressemble à celle de
la france donc les centres de personnes
âgées non autonomes ont été très
durement touchée donc c'est soit le
nombre élevé de personnes âgées explique
d'abord pour que montréal est aussi
touchée
deuxièmement la distanciation sociale
qui aurait été plus difficile à
appliquer dans certains quartiers dans
des quartiers peut-être un peu moins
riche donc ceci la deuxième explication
troisième explication peut-être une plus
grande réticence des canadiens français
des québécois appliquer les mesures de
confinement peut être les restes d'un
certain esprit latin qui aurait fait en
sorte que les gens c'est ça était plus
raide saint appliqué les consignes que
dans le canada anglais
ou peut-être que les gens ont une
culture peu plus puritaine plus proche
de certaines hygiénisme si je faisais
pourtant vous le confirmer les mêmes
mesures de confinement ont été mises en
place partout dans le pays
à peu près c'est à dire que ce sont les
provinces un client qui ont été appelés
à développer les programmes d'urgence
des programmes de protection des
populations donc chaque province avait
son plein donc la santé c'est un domaine
de compétence provinciale au canada donc
évidemment aidé quelques divergences
mais on peut dire que dans l'ensemble la
fédération a les provinces ont appliqué
sensiblement le même programme donc la
déception est d'autant plus grande au
québec on se pose des questions pourquoi
le québec 1 et plus touchée est moins
bon je viens de
vous donnez des facteurs explicatifs
mais je vous dis que au départ il y
avait un fort vent d'optimisme au québec
les québécois ont eu l'impression de se
retrouver autour d'une cause commune et
malheureusement avec le pain cet
optimisme s'est complètement dégonflé
est évidemment une certaine examen de
conscience qui va devoir être faits au
québec parce que de 22% de la population
1 au québec le québec c'est 1 2% la
population canadienne mais c'est plus de
50 % des cas dans l'ensemble la
fédération donc alors en france nous
avons une règle 1 on ne peut pas
dépasser les fameux 100 km ça arrange
peut-être certains ont province 1 qui
sont en zone verte de ne pas voir tous
ces parisiens débarquer sur leur
territoire est ce que la crainte et la
même par exemple de ne pas voir
justement les gens de montréal les
habitants de montréal débarquer dans des
zones moins touchés vous l'avez dit du
québec
oui je te fais c'est un peu cocasse
parce que bon et comme un frein c'est ça
il ya un décalage entre ce qu'on appelle
la province ici on dit les régions en
france on dit la presse qui la métropole
montréal le grand montréal
donc oui plusieurs maires des
municipalités des organismes régionaux
qui ont exprimé des craintes de voir
léman et allait débarquer à montréal
dans les régions c'est à dire un peu
comme un peu comme des zombies le voyais
qu'ils seraient là pour les contaminés
en même temps les régions et est un peu
épargné artificiellement par la pandémie
parce que de nombreux barrages routiers
ont été mis en place dont certains
disent on ne veut pas de deuxième vague
au québec
mais ce que certains répondent c'est ce
ne soit pas une deuxième vague en région
ça va être une première vague parce que
les régions ont été préservés
officiellement de ça et en même temps
s'il fallait que les montréalais a mené
avec n'avait pas passer leurs vacances
estivales dans les régions ce serait une
petite catastrophe économique pour le
tourisme pour l'économie des régions
donc lieu du bourg est il contre dans
cette situation là donc les gens ont
peur mais en même temps ils ont si peur
pour leurs économies alors il ya le
voisin
américain également est ce qui
l'inquiète et frontières sont toujours
fermé les frontières sont fermées je
voudrais que ce qui inquiète encore un
plus et l'immigration clandestine qui a
été qui n'eut contrôler maintenant
depuis depuis une date les centres dont
j'oublie que j'oublie jacquemin mais
justin trudeau est beaucoup critiqué
pour ça même aujourd'hui parce que
beaucoup hésitent et affrontera fermer
les frontières avec les états unis aussi
elle lui a bloqué l'émigration
clandestine qui s'est poursuivie pendant
de nombreuses semaines
même en pleine pandémie donc des
migrants clandestins qui sont entrés au
canada chaque jour des dizaines avec
peut-être le virus on sait pas au début
il n'était pas testé finale mais
maintenant ils le sont ils ont ils ont
passé un examen santé ce sont des
demandeurs d'asile est ce qu'on a pu
découvrir qui dénonce un peu le portrait
c'est que plusieurs demandeurs d'asile
qui sont venus clandestinement il ya
quelques années travaillent maintenant
au front au front dans des centres de
personnages ils ont donc vous voyez que
c'est jamais ces jeunes et systèmes
alors il ya aussi un constat économique
difficile il ya quelques jours le 16 mai
la compagnie air canada a annoncé le
licenciement de 20000 employés sur 38
mills a dû être un sacré séisme pour le
canada cette nouvelle qui de fait non
l'économie canadienne va être donc
toutes les économies ralement du prêt
cela va être durement affectée par par
la situation au québec en particulier si
les pme et les pme a donc les petites
moyennes entreprises qui représentent à
peu près comme 85% du secteur privé donc
vous imaginez est à peu près la moitié
des pme ont déjà mis des gens à pied
donc on recommence à peine ressentir les
effets économiques de la crise à vannes
vraiment dans les prochaines semaines
comme ailleurs dans le monde qu'on va
découvrir l'infinie diversité des
domaines des travailleurs touchés par la
crise pendant ce temps là juste
renault multiplie les aides
gouvernementales c'est une forme une
sorte d'orgie financière c'est à dire
que vraiment justin trudeau est en train
de manger qu'il ya dans un déficit
historique et très l'état qui exclut
aussi pour ça parce que c'est peut-être
pas trop gêner relais de la biodynamie
donc certains craignent que les
canadiennes et aux canadiens un rouge
merci avons jérôme blanchet gravel
d'avoir été avec nous avoir parlé de la
situation au canada